avec volée une frappe bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour à la une de la presse
internationale hélène la presse
française pour commencer l'accélération
des livraisons d'armes occidental à
l'ukraine où les forces russes tentent
toujours de s'emparer de l'ensemble du
dombass alors que la presse
internationale on l'est évoqué ici a
largement fait état de la promesse du
président américain de livrer 20
milliards de dollars d'équipements
militaires offensif kiev 20 milliards
d'équipements militaires supplémentaires
cette stratégie est défendu dans le
parisien par le chercheur vincent
touraine de la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique qui explique que
la diplomatie et tente indexées aux
résultats sur le terrain les occidentaux
sont obligés de soutenir militairement
le cren pour aboutir précisément à des
négociations pour retrouver un dialogue
le quotidien l'humanité est en revanche
beaucoup plus sceptique selon lui les
etats-unis écartent tout danger de
frappe nucléaire russe s'est choisi
l'escaladé militaire au détriment de la
recherche de négociation paie le journal
cite le ministre de la défense américain
qui dit s'être donné pour objectif de le
site de voir la russie affaiblie un
degré tel qu'elle ne puisse pas faire le
même genre de choses que l'invasion de
l'ukraine et sur la photo à côté de vous
on voit le président ukrainien et la
patronne à des démocrates américains
nancy pelosi beaucoup de réactions qui
était en visite à kiev beaucoup de
réactions également du côté de la presse
africaine autre chose hélène après
l'annoncé samedi du chef de la junte
militaire en guinée qui a dit vouloir
établir la durée de la transition à 39
mois avant de rendre le pouvoir aux
civils 39 pas 36 ou 42 noms 39 c'est une
d'une précision d'horloger
l'observateur belga le quotidien
burkinabè se moque du chronogramme de
cette transition établi par mamadou
doumbouya le chef de la junte qui a
renversé la faconde et en septembre 2021
trois ans et trois mois donc un délai ni
acceptable ni raisonnable pour le
journal qui compare ce délai aux 36 mois
de transition exigé par paul-henri
damiba qui le chef de la junte au
pouvoir au burkina faso qui lui je cite
aurait au moins l'exploit à la tête d'un
pays dont une bonne partie est sous
l'emprise des terroristes ou encore aux
24 mois de transition demandé à 6 mio
état qui est le chef de la junte au
pouvoir au mali trente neuf mois de
transition en guinée en rire ou en
pleurer le site burkinabè wac est sert à
exprimer son inquiétude face à ce
printemps des coups d'état qui s'impose
à une afrique de l'ouest où les
démocraties prend décidément du plomb
dans l aile alors que ces populations en
sont encore à la recherche de solution à
la faim et aux maladies la
multiplication des coups d'état en
afrique de l'ouest qui menace également
la liberté de la presse il en sera
question demain en effet nous sommes à
la veille de la journée mondiale de la
liberté de la presse et le pays relève
que la mission des journalistes de
porter la plume dans la plaie n'est
souvent pas du goût des régimes kaki qui
font preuve d'une grande frilosité à
chaque fois qu une critique objective
contrarie leurs sombres desseins de
manipulation du peuple le journal
burkinabè qui cite l'exemple du mali
voisin convient d'évoquer en où rfi et
france 24 ont été définitivement
suspendu par les autorités de transition
met également en garde le président
burkinabè damiba dans ce pays de norbert
zongo le journaliste burkinabè assassiné
en
1998 on préfère je cite mourir aux
portes de la liberté que de pourrir dans
les enfers de la servitude et vous avez
cité les mots de notre maître à tous
albert londres porter la plume dans la
plaie effectivement on y reviendra
demain lors d'une journée spéciale sur
l'antenne 4 consacré à la journée
mondiale de la liberté de la presse en
france hélène les traditionnelles
manifestations du 1er mai ont pris un
tour hier très politique une semaine
tout juste après la victoire d'emmanuel
macron à la présidentielle les syndicats
français préviennent macron de financial
times évoque des rassemblements dominée
par les préoccupations concernant le
pouvoir d'achat les prix de l'énergie et
la réforme des retraites cadence et
emmanuel macron confrontée à son premier
grand défi de ce second quinquennat avec
les législatives le mois prochain des
élections que la gauche on cherche à
aborder dans l'unité le monde annonce
que le conseil fédéral d'europe écologie
verts a voté largement hier soir le
texte conclu avec la france un soumises
de jean-luc mélenchon les écologistes et
les insoumis comme les appelle formant
désormais la nouvelle union populaire
écologistes la nouvelle union populaire
écologiste et sociale j'en perds mon
latin les deux formations espèrent
désormais ouvrir la voie à d'autres
union avec le parti communiste avec
lequel un accord pourrait intervenir ces
prochaines heures et avec le parti
socialiste dont le patron olivier faure
a déjà accepté de négocier avec jean luc
mélenchon provoquant la colère d'une
partie de son propre camp qui craint de
se dissoudre au sein de la france
insoumise est ce la fin du ps
s'interroge le parisien qui voit les
socialistes en sursis le parisien le
dessin de rang sans montre des
socialistes en train de se déchirer pas
question de se soumettre de négocier
avec les insoumis si on a le droit d'y
certain maintenant on est là deux
gauches irréconciliables au sein mais au
sein du ps la perspective d'une union de
la gauche sous la houlette de jean luc
mélenchon pauline qui donne aussi des
sueurs froides à l'opinion qui évoque on
le voit
l'inexorable soumission de la gauche à
mélenchon elle ne s'était jamais
vraiment remise pour le court et les
non-dits demain on se dit à demain avec
un au revoir mais la reine des
noctambules parisiens s'en est allé
regina zylberberg dit régine est morte
hier à l'âge de 92 ans la nuit ça
concerne n'est ce pas pauline une
éclipse de le plume à la une de
libération en référence à la célèbre
chanson mon truc en plumes les amateurs
tels que moi de boas sont orphelins
peut-être tels que vous bel hommage
également du journal suisse le temps
emporté par la nuit titre ultime pour
celle que françoise sagan bonjour
tristesse avait baptisée la reine noire
de nuit blanche la nuit ça concerne la
fat aussi n'est ce pas hélène merci
beaucoup à